[Applause]
[Music]
this morning on our Saturday session
indie music legend Liz Phair she rocked
the music patriarchy back in the 1990s
and in her new memoir she describes what
it was like to be a young female
musician in a male-dominated industry
she'll perform for us in just a minute
but first her conversation with Anthony
Mason it's been more than a quarter
century since Liz Phair released her
landmark debut exile in guy Ville a
sexually frank stab at the musical
patriarchy but many rank among the
greatest albums of the 90s
how do you feel about that first record
all these years later the time and
distance makes it much easier to embrace
don't I guess I like it a lot more now
what would you have disliked about it
back in the day yeah it made me feel so
self-conscious I felt inadequate like I
felt like when people heard the record
they would hear my awkward voice my
awkward warbly voice but that's not what
people heard at the time it wasn't but
it mystified me had walk around going
like what is this magic trick
she'd performed the trick again with
hits like why can't I
[Music]
but fair has had long periods when she
slipped in and out of rock stardom which
is indicative of what I'm uncomfortable
with being the star kind of you are a
little bit I ham it up you know how you
overcompensate when you're uncomfortable
about something but I am like a bookish
nerdish introvert yeah who just doesn't
want to be invisible or irrelevant the
bookish singer has now written her own
book horror stories a magically lyrical
memoir that is also searingly honest my
conscience fair writes is a fantastic
prosecutor was the hardest part to write
about probably the affair I had at the
end of my marriage or the me to chapter
the hashtag-- chapter about the sexual
harassment that I've experienced in my
life I've had a president of a record
label
show me pornographic picture books in
his office she writes another label head
tells her to let radio programmers feel
me up a little because it would be good
for my career a third label exec offers
her $5,000 a month to be his live-in
mistress he probably never done
something like that before should have
added it all up
I had never added it all up I had never
even even in therapy I never even talked
about it to anyone
it's how did it feel to write about it
horrible really horrible I hated that
chapter I don't like to see myself as a
victim I mean I'm almost kind of tearing
up right now because I don't like to
feel like a victim mm-hmm I feel sorry
for that girl that I was I wish I could
go back and help her out or hold her
hand or yell at someone for her if you
write it down it goes into that page and
some part of it leaves you not all of it
but like it's a relief fear also
describes a painful breakup about a
decade ago with a longtime boyfriend who
had a baby with another woman that
sounded just devastating it was
changed the trajectory of my life that
breakup destroyed my ability to trust
myself and so I pulled out of dating and
I just kind of became paralyzed I guess
for how long I'm still working on it
in the aftermath fair focused on raising
her son Nick then when I wanted to get
back into music after he went to college
I didn't know who I was I didn't know
who Liz Phair was so what did you think
it happened to Liz Phair she seemed way
cooler than I was and way tougher how
did you find her again
honestly playing live playing live
[Music]
scary because that adrenaline rush right
and if you pull it off if you pull it
off you feel like a living god you're
just like invincible fabulous